es war kurzem war ich der meinung dass
wir mehr wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in den medien braucht
mehr stimmen der vernunft doch krone
meine meinung geändert jetzt wo mein
wunsch in erfüllung gegangen ist dass
wissenschaft viel mehr aufmerksamkeit
bekommt muss ich einsehen ach nee im
wissenschaftler sind ja gar nicht
automatisch stimmen der für nun packt
die und wenn sie es nicht sind dann ist
das ein verdammt großes problem
ein viel größeres problem als irgend
eine knalltüte die bei telegramm was von
einer bill gates verschwörung fantasiert
denn die mehrheit der bevölkerung weiß
ja dass das signal tüte ist aber
wissenschaftler sind experten auf deren
expertise die mär der bevölkerung
vertraut und vertrauen ist genau das
richtige wort denn wie kann ich als laie
die expertise einer expertin überprüfen
das muss sich ändern
holt euch in theley erstmal eine
wichtige unterscheidung es gibt
wissenschaft und es gibt wissenschaftler
und das problem mit wissenschaftlern ist
sie sind menschen ich habe nichts gegen
menschen einige meiner besten freunde
sind mensch aber menschen können nie zu
100 prozent sachlich sein du nicht ich
nicht wir menschen haben meinungen
menschen haben politische haltungen
menschen haben ideologien menschen haben
wie heißt es aber dieses andere
unlogische zeug emotionen und kann
menschen nicht trauen ihr wisst was ich
meine man kann sich nicht auf ihre
sachliche korrektheit verlassen und
genau deswegen gibt es beim
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten verschiedene
vorkehrungen damit wissenschaft obwohl
sie von menschen mit all ihren
menschlichen fehlern durchgeführt wird
so sachlich und verlässlich wie möglich
wird was sind das für vorkehrungen zum
beispiel wissenschaftliche methoden
wissenschaftlich arbeiten heißt nicht
einfach nur daten sammeln sondern auch
kontrollprozesse einführen zb von troll
experimente blinden das angehen von
viele balken schätzung statistischer
signifikanz und so weiter methoden sind
oft das was
in der studie besser oder schlechter
macht zwei spielen momentan werden ja
viele heilmittel gegen 9.10 angeboten
die angeblich in studien wirksam waren
nur dass das studiendesign dann ungefähr
so aussieht wir haben 20 kurven 19
infizierte am besten alles sonst gesunde
junge erwachsene täglich eine stunde
lagen mit lauch abgeklopft und siehe da
sie wurden alle wieder gesund das sagt
gar nichts aus weil die meisten gesunden
erwachsenen nach kurve 19 dann auch
wieder gesund wären also abgesehen von
potenziellen dank zeit schäden aber da
verweise ich auf unsere quarks fünf
minuten corona folge in der video
beschreibung denn jetzt aber jemand eine
studie vorlegen kann bei der nicht 20
sondern 2009/10 infizierte untersucht
wurden darunter auch menschen aus
risikogruppen +2 tausende infizierte
einer kontrollgruppe mit derselben
demographie und die testgruppe mit lauch
abgeklopft wurde die kontrollgruppe aber
nur mit placebo rauch und die testgruppe
dann statistisch signifikant schneller
oder öfter gesund wurde als die
kontrollgruppe ja dann kaufte lauf sind
ernst auch als laie sollte man immer
versuchen wissenschaftliche methoden so
gut es geht nachzuvollziehen um
wissenschaft einordnen zu können also
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse alleine
sagen meist wenig aus solange man die
wissenschaftlichen methoden nicht kennt
zweitens die kritischen kollegen
kilometer und wissenschaftlicher diskurs
wenn ich wollte könnte ich wohl die
vitamintabletten beim tm kaufen sie in
antritt lesen umfüllen und sie für das
zehnfache geld als brain booster pillen
verkaufen oder ich könnte meinen schweiß
auffangen das wasser verdunsten und den
rest zu tabletten pressen und dann als
brain booster pillen verkaufen es wäre
aber gar nicht so leicht irgend so eine
schrottlaube prinzip über diese brain
booster pillen zu veröffentlichen also
ich kenne natürlich irgendwas auf meiner
homepage oder so veröffentlichen aber
das ist ja keine anerkannte
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung das
heißt wissenschaftlich erstligist wenn
sie ordentlich veröffentlicht ist denn
eine veröffentlichung muster so genannte
peer review bestehen eine überprüfung
durch andere fachleute die in
aller regel korrekturen und
überarbeitungen fordern und was am ende
nicht überzeugen kann wird abgelehnt das
preview ist jetzt leider kein perfekter
kontrollprozess es werden wie gesagt
bessere und leider auch schlechtere
studien veröffentlicht nur nach der
veröffentlichung geht der
wissenschaftliche kritische diskurs ja
auch noch weiter es kommt zum beispiel
vor dass antwort artikel von
fachkollegen die irgendeine
veröffentlichung sachlich widersprechen
im selben journal veröffentlicht werden
also mit einem harten aber sachlichen
diskurs wird in der wissenschaft viel
offener umgegangen als anderswo was eben
zur qualitätssicherung beiträgt drittens
das puzzle prinzip die sachen so schön
eine studie ist keine studie als ich
selbst noch in der forschung war hat
mich oft frustriert wie un- bedeutet man
so als einzelne wissenschaftlerin ist
also auch nach jahrelanger intensiver
arbeit ist ein beitrag zur
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnis noch nicht
einmal ein kleines rädchen in einem
großen uhrwerk sondern nur so ein
zähnchen auf einem rädchen oder sagen
wir nur ein staubkorn auf dem zehnten
eines mädchens eines großen uhrwerks nur
dass das uhrwerk noch gar nicht läuft
und die uhr erst noch erfunden werden
muss wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse
setzen sich nun mal aus vielen kleinen
puzzleteilen zusammen es braucht in der
regel viele verschiedene studien viele
verschiedene forschungsgruppen und viele
viele jahre ist sich ein konsistentes
bild zusammensetzt es ist einerseits
anstrengend andererseits ist es auch gut
dass eben nicht einzelne autoritäten
ihre meinung durchsetzen können sondern
dass nur die gesamt datenlage überzeugt
und das verschiedene ergebnisse auch
konsistent zusammenpassen müssen damit
ein wissenschaftlicher konsens entsteht
das waren jetzt drei gründe warum
wissenschaft verlässlich ist obwohl sie
von menschen gemacht wird und daraus
leiten wir beim imap auch regeln für
unsere arbeit ab erzählen nicht nur von
wissenschaftlichen ergebnissen sondern
versuchen auch nachvollziehbar zu machen
wie die experten darauf gekommen sind
die versuchen wo es nur möglich ist uns
auf peer reviewed originalliteratur zu
beziehen und drittens prinzip versuchen
möglichst viele studien zu lesen
wir schauen uns auch so genannte
literature reviews an die einen
überblick über verschiedene studien zum
selben thema geben wir schauen nach meta
analysen rom mehrere studien zu einer
großen auswertung zusammen verarbeitet
werden und wir schauen auch nach
stellungnahmen und
forschungsgemeinschaften oder
fachgesellschaften wo sich mehrere
expertinnen und experten auf eine
stellung oder einen konsens geeinigt
haben und den geschlossen kommuniziert
singt gut oder aber ihr die ihr meine
videos schaut müsstet ihr eigentlich
alle unsere quellen selbst durchlesen um
zu überprüfen ob ich nicht irgendwo
erzähle was die meisten aber stress
machen ist mir einfach vertrauen oder
grundsätzlich misstrauen das gibt's
natürlich auch jetzt kommt das
eigentlich verrückt die haben ja
wenigstens noch quellen unter unseren
videos aber wenn jetzt wissenschaftler
im fernsehen auftreten oder zeitungs
interviews geben sind da meistens keine
quellen angegeben weil die experten
selbst die quelle ist aber wenn wir ganz
konsequent denken wissenschaftlich
denken warum sollten wir expertinnen
oder experten in der zeitung im
fernsehen einfach so vertrauen crosby
eines eint ist typischerweise zu den
wissenschaftler so sachlich das ist fast
schon nervt schön dass sie hier sind
hatten sie eine gute anreise
nun gut oder schlecht kann man ja so
pauschal nicht sagen es gibt ganz
interessante hinweise aus verkehrs
wissenschaftlicher finde also gar nicht
dass bei den meisten wissenschaftlern
die sachlichkeit ein problem ist sondern
eher die verständlichkeit aber wenn
experten es mal nicht so genau nehmen
mit der sachlichkeit
dann kann das großen schaden anrichtet
indem man leute fragen würde warum
vertrauen sie wissenschaftlern wenn es
um wissenschaft geht würden die meisten
sagen weil die experten sind weil die
sich damit auskennen aber hat keine der
punkte die ich im letzten kapitel
genannt habe mit expertise zu tun
sondern mit kontrolle und überprüft
natürlich die expertise ist das was ein
experten überhaupt erst zum experten
macht keine frage nur expertise ist
keine garantie für vertrauenswürdigkeit
oder verlässlichkeit es gibt
verschiedene gründe warum experten nicht
automatisch korrekt sind sie erinnern
unsere das problem wissenschaftler sind
menschen
wissenschaftler können eitel sein oder
rivalitäten untereinander
beispiel thomas edison erfinder der
glühbirne und anscheinend auch ein
riesen arsch im zuge des berühmten strom
kriegs gegen seinen rivalen nikola tesla
gleichstrom wirst es wechselstrom
versuchte er die menschen von seinem
gleichstrom zu überzeugen indem er an
streunenden hunden demonstrierte wie
tödlich wechselstrom doch sei
wissenschaftler können auch politische
ideologien haben die ihre sachlichkeit
trüben nobelpreisträger james watson der
die struktur der dna mit entschlüsselte
wurde später leider auch bekannt für
rassistische antisemitische und
sexistische statements die er teilweise
auch wissenschaftlich begründet und
nobelpreisträger können tatsächlich auch
mal falsch liegen chemie
nobelpreisträger linus pauling war zum
beispiel davon überzeugt dass absurd
hohe dosen vitamin c nicht nur vor
erkältungen sondern sogar vor krebs
schützen wie sie wirklich ist video von
uns in die infokarte oder noch krasser
chemienobelpreis rehacare ihm alles
entwickelte die pcr technik auf der auch
die korona tests basieren war aber auch
gleichzeitig ein knallharter aids
leugner alter und selbst wenn solche
fälle eher selten sind können auch
wenige verquere experten viel schaden
anrichten denn wenn es nobelpreisträger
aids leugner ist dann hat irgendwie
verschwörungs fantasie die vorher
einfach nur knallt ich war dann
plötzlich eine vermeintliche
wissenschaftliche basis während sich
absurde ideen in der wissenschaft nur
schwer durchsetzen ist es in den medien
eine ganz andere geschichte medien
lieben alles was aus der reihe tanzt
große bühne für schwarze schafe uns
haben so viele nachrichten zu professor
südback die erreicht der gerade mit
seinem expertenstatus aber
wissenschaftlich unhaltbaren
falschaussagen viele bücher verkauft
viele von euch haben sich einen
faktencheck gewünscht zu sein aussagen
oder zu seinem buch kuroda fehlalarm
dass er zusammen mit seiner ehefrau
professor crey der reis schrieb die
dermatologin ist an der uni kiel also
ich werde mit wachsender reichweite
dieses kanals auch zunehmend
vorsichtiger wem ich diese reichweite
schenke manche aussagen oder
desinformation möchte man einfach nicht
wiederholen
um sie zu die banken einfach um diesen
ideen nicht noch mehr aufmerksamkeit zu
geben
aber da das buch corona fehler da
entschuldigung kroner viel alarm eine
ganz offene frage spiegel bestseller ist
und damit ohnehin sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit bekommt möchte ich die
gelegenheit nutzen und die
aufmerksamkeit auf die uni kiel lenken
wie etwas getan hat dass ich mir von
viel mehr experten wünschen würde und
zwar nachdem die beiden anfang august
den kieler nachrichten ein interview
über ihr buch gaben reagierte die
christian albrechts universität zu kiel
mit zwei stellungnahmen indem sie sich
von ihrer eigenen professoren
distanzieren eine im namen der
hochschullehrerinnen und hochschullehrer
der medizinischen fakultät unter zeigt
unter anderem vom dekan der fakultät und
eine weitere der fachschaft medizin sie
widersprechen entschieden den unbelegten
und im gegensatz zu seriösen
internationalen wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen stehenden behauptungen von
frau professor rhys und herrn professor
packt was die kieler mediziner hier tun
ist das was man auch innerhalb der
wissenschaftlichen community tun würde
fehlerhaft der veröffentlichungen werden
zurückgezogen und oder richtig gestellt
doch außerhalb der wissenschaftlichen
community gibt es solche regel nicht
weil meinungsfreiheit also ich hab
nichts gegen meinungsfreiheit einige
meiner besten freunde haben
meinungsfreiheit geht mir nicht in den
kopf warum innerhalb der wissenschaft
jede noch so kleine ungenauigkeit fünf
mal hinterfragt wird und alles
wasserfest belegt werden muss aber wenn
professoren diese babel verlassen und an
die breite öffentlichkeit treten das
wird er nicht mehr kontrolliert und
überprüft denn hier gilt der
meinungsfreiheit also schaudert an die
uni kiel die sich von ihrer eigenen
professorin distanziert hat von der uni
mainz also actis alma mater war vor
seinem ruhestand professor für
mikrobiologie an der uniklinik mainz
habe ich nur diese stellungnahme
gefunden
das war noch im märz da ging es um seine
aussagen in videos selbstverständlich
hat herr buck die als bürger das recht
seine eigene meinung zu vertreten
nur dass er halt als bürger sehr
wahrscheinlich kein bestseller
geschrieben hätte sondern eben nur als
professor diese ist jedoch in keiner
weise darauf legen wir wert mit der
universitätsmedizin mainz abgestimmt da
ich das ist eine sehr schwache
distanzierung empfinde habe ich bei der
uni mainz noch einmal nach
fragt die und in mainz erklärte
daraufhin dass die universitätsleitung
oder der vorstand der
universitätsmedizin grundsätzlich nicht
die wissenschaftlichen aussagen ihrer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
kommentiert was in den meisten fällen
auch nur richtig so ist aber in manchen
fällen gehört ist meiner meinung nach so
der verantwortung von wissenschaftlichen
institutionen auch stellung zu beziehen
zb wenn falschinformationen ein
massenpublikum erreichen
immerhin arbeitet die uni mainz derzeit
an einer deutlichen und sachlich
fundierten distanzierung das ist gut und
wichtig finde ich denn ohne seinen
expertenstatus ehemalige professor der
uni mainz hätte partie überhaupt nicht
den einfluss den er hat und wir
journalisten müssen besser darin werden
vernünftigen stimmen mehr aufmerksamkeit
zu geben denn liezen der uni der
stellungnahme raus bringt aber es keiner
liest dann sitzen experten in
fernsehshows oder mit spiegel
bestsellern am längeren hebel
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
nicht nur extremfälle wie reis oder
bakterien der wissenschaftlichen
aufklärung
denn letztendlich richten medien ja so
ein bisschen brain gym spotlights auf
einzelne experten und die große mehrheit
der wissenschaftler zum beispiel die
große mehr der virologen traut sich ja
gar nicht in die öffentlichkeit und das
sind gar nicht sichtbar
dadurch haben einzelne experten sehr
viel einfluss
viele gehen damit verantwortungsvoll um
aber wer garantiert uns dass nicht
irgendein experte seine einzelmeinung
als anerkannte expertise verkauft
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass dieses
kritische qualitätsmanagement was
innerhalb der wissenschaftlichen
community betrieben wird
auch in der wissenschaftskommunikation
an die breite bevölkerung greift
wissenschaft beruht nicht auf vertrauen
sondern auf hinterfragen auf kontrolle
und überprüfung das ist das was
wissenschaft so verlässlich macht so
lange in der wissenschaftskommunikation
nicht dieselben standards
an sachlichkeit und verlässlichkeit
gelten wie in der wissenschaft selbst
bringen mehr wissenschaftler in den
medien nicht mehr aufklärung sondern
mehr verwirrung dass mir jedenfalls erst
durch corona so richtig klar geworden
mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar wieso
eine qualitätskontrolle in der
wissenschaftskommunikation sinnvoll
geregelt aussehen könnte vielleicht
könnte man eine art qualitätssiegel
einführen oder sowas wie die zulassung
für wissenschaftskommunikatoren
vielleicht habt ihr ideen für regeln
schreibt sie in die kommentare
und in der end karte sich noch was
verrücktes erzählen
vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen dass
dieses video eine woche zu spät kam also
eigentlich hätte man schon letzte woche
kommen sollen
aber letzte woche war ich in berlin
ich habe ein bundesverdienstkreuz
bekommen ich fühle mich so geehrt und
ich alles also wenn diese entgeht sehr
zerstückelt ist dann liegt es daran dass
ich nicht genau weiß was ich sagen soll
also was ich sagen kann wird was
angemessen ist nämlich nichts herzlich
wird auch nochmal an alle anderen ordens
trägerinnen und träger shopper in die
video beschreibung da findet ihr ganz
viele tolle menschen die ich auch in
berlin mit sicherheitsabstand treffen
durfte ich habe mich auch mit dem
bundespräsidenten zusammengesetzt wir
haben ein kurzes gespräch über
wissenschaft und gewissermaßen auch über
wissenschaftskommunikation geführt wenn
ihr unser gespräch anschauen möchte
schaut man die video beschreibung
ansonsten wir sehen uns nächste woche
und bis dahin bleibt sicher